[MUSIC PLAYING]
RETO MEIER: Good
morning, everyone.
My name is Reto Meier.
I'm a developer
advocate here at Google.
Now, technically, I'm a DA on
the Google Cloud DevRel team.
So if any of you
bump into my boss
or I mean really anyone
from the Google Cloud team,
and they ask how the
presentation went,
if you could tell them that I
presented how to build a Cloud
backend for your mobile app,
that would really help me out.
Now, what I am presenting is
hopefully what everyone is here
to see, is Android
Protips, a fresh look
at expert advice for
advanced Android developers.
As the title suggests, this
will be a very technical talk.
There will be a lot of code.
If you are not
comfortable with code,
or if you came to hopefully
see the Grateful Dead,
you are in the wrong place.
You are also about
20 years late.
Now, just to get a
feel for to make sure
we have the right people in
the audience, how many of you
are developing for
Android right now?
I mean, not now now, but
like at home and at work.
OK.
Most of you.
Not everyone.
That's cool.
Like there's some Android
curious folks here.
Some dead heads in the
wrong place and time.
I think there's some
folks up on the bank
just working on their tan.
And that's cool too.
Everyone's welcome.
Thank you for coming.
Now, this is actually a pretty
special year for Android.
This marks the
10-year anniversary
of Android Development,
which is super exciting.
Obviously, not everyone's
been developing
on Android for quite that long.
How many have you
been developing
for more than two years?
Yeah?
Wow.
Five years?
A few hands down.
What about 10 years?
Do we have any
ten-year veterans?
A few.
Nice.
Congratulations.
Yeah, round of applause
for the 10 years.
I, too, have that
honor, that privilege
of having been developing
for Android for 10 years.
I even brought receipts.
This is my very first
question on Stack Overflow,
asking about the Maps
API for the 0.9 beta SDK,
which those handful
of 10-year veterans
will hopefully remember,
maybe hopefully not remember.
This is not my first
Google I/O. This
is not my first Protip session.
So I'm curious, and this
will be the last question
I ask for a little while
at least, how many of you
have been to a previous and
seen one of my previous Protip
sessions?
That's a decent handful.
All right.
And you still came to this.
That's reassuring.
So thank you for that.
I actually spent
a fair bit of time
over the last couple
of months looking back
over these sessions.
And at first, it
was because I wanted
to gain some inspiration.
You know, like, what
are the cool things
we used to talk about?
Gain some of the excitement
from the early days of Android.
But I quickly realized
that not everything
that I had said in those early
days has held up all that well.
So as a result, what I'm
actually going to be presenting
this year is looking
at all the things
that we've said
in previous years
and giving it a
bit of an update.
So the real, real title
slide for today's session
is actually Android
Protips Fixed.
Sorry.
So the goal here
is to provide you
with all the tips and
tricks and best practices
and good advice
that's going to help
us develop great apps for
the next decade of Android
development.
And in order to do
that effectively,
I want you to take the
same journey as me.
So we're going to start
by going back in time.
We're going to go back
through previous Google
I/Os, previous Protip
sessions, all the way back
to the very, very beginning.
OK.
We may have gone too far back.
This is me in kindergarten.
Happy child.
I don't know what a
fragment is, and I've never
heard of a content provider.
That will change.
Also, side note, I didn't
know I was presenting
in the amphitheater,
and that there
would be a 400 foot screen.
If I had known that,
I may have included
fewer pictures of myself.
Take note if you're
ever in this situation.
Clearly, we're too far back.
So let's just bump it
a few years forward.
I think I can do that
with one of these buttons.
Let's have a look.
Yes.
Yeah, this is more like it.
Don't I look young?
This is 2008.
And I remember this,
because this is actually
the cover photo for
my first Android book.
And we took this
photo just after I'd
gotten the first
round of editor notes
back from the first draft.
And the next day, Android
released the 1.0 SDK.
And up until then, I'd been
writing based on the 0.9 beta.
And I knew what was coming.
You know, the clue
was in the name.
But I figured how much
is going to change?
Right?
1.0 from 0.9, 0.8 to
0.9 was pretty minor,
so it should just be a
couple of little things.
Turns out a lot can
change, like really a lot.
I'd actually written an entire
chapter on the [? G Talk ?]
data API, which it
was pretty cool,
but it did not exist
in the 1.0 SDK.
It's 30 pages of hard work.
I didn't remove it.
I ended up leaving it in the
book, because by the time
it came out, who knows?
Right?
Android moves quickly.
Well, it's been 10 years.
It never got put back in.
And eventually, I removed
it from future revisions
of the book.
Anyway, the reason
I mention this
is because I've spent
most of the past 10 years
going around talking
about Android,
giving advice on the best way
of doing things, the latest
and greatest APIs that
you can take advantage
of to build great apps.
And I do this with the
knowledge that sometimes
within months, even weeks, these
things are going to change.
They're going to be
replaced with something more
efficient, more comprehensive.
And in fact, weeks and months
is a best case scenario.
I remember one
particular incident.
I had just finished a
keynote, very exciting.
Google Developer
Day in Prague, I
think it was, What's
New in Cupcake.
I've been doing
this for a while.
And I stepped off stage.
And just as my foot hit the
ground, we released Donut.
So in that instance, I had
about three nanoseconds
of being current before
everything I said
was effectively outdated.
Now, despite how all
of that may sound,
this is actually
really a good thing.
Well, for you, not
so much for me.
But for you, it's a good thing.
It demonstrates
how quickly Android
is evolving to give users and
developers the things that they
need to be able
to be successful.
There's always been a trade-off.
And I know you all have
felt this pain where
the new platform comes
out, awesome new APIs,
great new functionality
to take advantage of.
But you know it's going to take
a while before lots of users
are on that platform.
And at the same time, some
of the older platforms
are going to take a few
years before they go away.
So you have to do
this trade-off.
Is it worth putting
in the time and effort
to take advantage of the new
APIs, the new functionality,
knowing that it's going to have
to be backwards compatible,
and you're going to have to
maintain that code potentially
for years.
So when do you do that?
Well, the thing is what makes
us really excited is that now we
have Jetpack, right, which
incorporates all of the Android
Support Library, Android
Architecture components.
And if you take Jetpack and
combine it with Google Play
Services, we end up with
an increasing surface area
of APIs, which don't rely on
having the latest platform
version.
So you can take advantage of
the new functionality that's
available.
And we'll take care of writing
all of the boilerplate code
to make it backwards
compatible for you.
So this is a nice advantage.
Right?
Suddenly that trade-off
isn't quite as expensive.
Now, it's still one of
the big pluses of this
as well is that we're no
longer tied to the framework.
Right?
So we can continue to
launch new features,
fix bugs, encapsulate
more best practices,
take care of more edge cases.
We can do all of this in
between platform releases, which
is great for developers,
not so awesome for those
of us trying to talk about it.
Things change more rapidly.
But there's a price.
Right?
If you want to take advantage
of this cool new stuff,
you have to reconsider some of
the fundamental architectural
choices in how we
build our apps.
And so I'm going to talk
today a little bit about why
I think now is the
right time to do that.
But if we bring it down
to its real fundamentals,
what we're trying to
do is keep our app
looking fresh, lightweight,
full of potential.
If not, we quickly risk becoming
visibly older, outdated,
a little bloated maybe, harder
to maintain, harder to manage.
And there's an analogy
for high cholesterol,
but I couldn't figure it out.
You get the idea.
Right?
So before we sort
of dive into some
of the tips, which
we do need to update,
I did want to spend just
a little bit of time
highlighting a handful
of Protips which
have stood the test of
time, that like a fine wine
or a sharp cheddar,
actually aged pretty well.
There's probably more than
just the ones on this list.
But this is the highlights.
And what you'll notice about
these particular Protips
is that they're not really
specific to Android.
They're not even really
specific to mobile development.
This is just good best
practice that you should always
be keeping in mind when
building any engineering app.
So let's not dwell
too much on the things
that we know are
still good ideas.
Let's take a look at some of
the things which have changed,
which have perhaps not
aged quite as well.
Now, everything on this list
you can pretty much still do,
but it's all been replaced
with newer APIs that
are more efficient, that
encapsulate a bigger
amount of functionality.
Sometimes the underlying
hardware has changed
or the UI paradigm has changed.
But a lot of it
you can still do.
And that's actually kind of a
theme for a lot of the things
that we're going
to be looking at.
There has always been ways
of achieving certain things,
but there's now significantly
better ways, simpler ways which
involve less code,
less hacky workarounds,
making it more predictable
and easier for you
to maintain and manage your
code bases going forward.
So we know things have changed.
I've said that a few times.
But there's certain things we've
always been able to rely on.
Right?
You write your Android code
in Java language syntax.
And all of the
application components
are basically the same.
We use the same core components.
They interact the same way.
They achieve the
same end results.
And that's something we've
been able to rely on until--
basically, until now.
The last year or so things
have fundamentally changed.
Android Studio 3
introduced Kotlin
as a first class language
for Android development.
And that's actually what
we're encouraging people
to use as their
primary development
language for Android.
We saw the introduction
of Android Architecture
Components, which introduced
ViewModels, LiveData,
and the Room Database to
significantly simplify
the way we manage data and
have it interact properly
with the activity lifecycle.
We also have the JobScheduler,
which almost entirely
eliminates the need to create
your own custom background
services and the
intent receivers
that we sometimes set up to
monitor device state to control
when our services are
run, which is a good thing
because in Android 0 we
actually deprecated the ability
to have long running
background services
when your app is in
the background as well.
And at the same time, most
of the intent receivers
that you may have used
to monitor device state
have also largely
been deprecated.
Another good thing, of
course, things move quickly.
JobScheduler already deprecated
as of yesterday morning.
So now we have
Work Manager, which
is nice because it does the
same stuff as JobScheduler,
but it's backwards compatible.
All right?
So you're starting to see
some of the trends of what
we're trying to achieve here.
So we should dig into some
of this stuff in a little bit
more detail.
And something which I've talked
about it most of these Protip
sessions was the first thing
I talked about and comes up
every year, I like
to focus on what's
happening in the background.
Sometimes it's easy to miss
until you really focus on it.
So the first Protip
I gave, back in 2010,
first session, first
Android session,
first real session on a big
stage, was very exciting.
And this was the first Protip.
So I thought let's have
a look at what I said,
and see how well it holds up.
So this is the first
thing I ever advised.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- So it's important
that you move anything
which can in any way take
longer than just a fraction
of a second and interrupt
the UI flow that you move it
into a background thread.
So there's a number of
ways you can do that.
The most simple
and straightforward
is, of course, just
to use Java Threading.
What we've created in Android
is a task called async task.
[END PLAYBACK]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
RETO MEIER: Yeah, you
know what they say,
the giant screen actually
removes 20 pounds.
So it's kind of true.
Right?
Like, kind of, like we don't
want to block the UI thread.
But the context around
what I was talking about
was trying to eliminate
these application
not responding dialogs, which
have evolved over the years.
They look a little
bit different now.
They used to be very
common because it
was easy to block the
foreground thread.
Right?
If you tried to do
a data transfer,
for example, it would block and
that would be a bad experience.
And so for Android 3.0, we
introduced a runtime exception.
So if you tried to
access the internet
through our runtime exception,
the app would crash.
Strong encouragement for
developers to not do that.
More recently, we've
done similar things
with file system access with
database access as well.
Now, in Android P this
is no longer a problem
because we don't
show ANR dialogs.
We just crash the app.
So that's not a better
outcome for your users.
But it's a much stronger
signal to us as developers
that we need to make sure
that we're taking care
of this particular problem.
Now, I did mention one
solution, and it got
some love, the old async task.
It's a reasonable solution
to the stated problem.
We need to move everything
off the foreground
onto a background thread.
And that's what async task does.
Creates a background
thread, and then it
has these two handlers
which are called.
Marshall back to
the UI thread so you
can update the UI when you've
got progress or a final result
to display.
I would like to tell you
that the only thing missing
from that is that now you
have to write it in Kotlin.
It's better.
Kotlin looks nicer.
It's certainly more concise.
But you still have the
same fundamental problem,
where if you're doing this
stuff within an activity,
if the user rotates the phone,
it's all going to go wrong.
Right?
Your thread is going to get
killed, your async task.
And that's kind of your
best case scenario.
You may leak context.
You may try and
update a UI element
that just doesn't exist, or
is in the process of getting
killed and recreated.
It's problematic.
Now, back in that
first I/O session,
I had a solution for this.
It was a great solution.
The advice was
you should move it
to a service, which it's fair
to say this advice has not
aged spectacularly well.
Now, the general principle
is still pretty reasonable.
Right?
It's like you have
something long running,
so you're in your
activity, you use
an intent to start a service,
probably an intent service.
And that goes and does
the time consuming work.
Maybe it's pulling
something down from a server
or interacting with a
database or performing
some complex calculation.
And when it's finished, it sends
an intent back to the activity.
And it then updates
the UI accordingly.
Basic stuff.
And it's a reasonable approach.
But it does introduce
some new challenges.
Services are
heavyweight components.
Right?
We don't really
want to create them.
We want to kill them
as quickly as possible
to gain back some of
their system resources.
And they keep running, even
when your activity isn't, which
is kind of the point.
But now you have to keep in
mind your activity lifecycle.
What's it doing?
Have you actually
exited the app?
Have you transitioned
to a new activity?
Should the service keep running?
Should it be canceled?
All of this stuff you
need to keep in mind.
And it's doable.
It's just a lot of
work to get right.
And of course, because services
run at a high priority,
it actually prevents the
system from killing your app
to gain resources
if it needs to.
And there's no guarantee that
your service will actually
keep running if your
app is forced quit.
So there's another problem,
which is in Android O,
you can't guarantee that your
background services will be
running when you want them to.
You can't start a
background service
when your app is in the
background from a broadcast
receiver.
And they will be killed
after a few minutes,
even if they were initiated
while your activity was
in the foreground.
Now, for really
time-consuming things,
which you need to have run, this
is still a reasonable approach.
You have an activity,
uses the service
to then download
data from a server,
say, nice time-consuming
operation.
And then that saves
it to a database.
And then your activity
just monitors the database.
So it's kind of a one-way
flow, which is nice.
But there is a catch.
There's always a catch.
And the catch is that this
is not an efficient way
to use the cell radio.
And back in 2012, I'm not going
to go into too much detail,
but I had this whole spiel
about how the cell radio works.
And every time
you do a transfer,
it turns on the radio.
It stays in a standby state,
which draws more power.
And the goal is that it reduces
latency for future transfers.
That's all great.
And the reason it's
important for us to know
is that if you're doing
lots of transfers,
you can keep the
radio turned on.
It's going to draw
power more quickly.
So we have some specific
advice for this, which
was you should deal with that.
You know how it works now.
Efficiency is
important, so fix it.
I had this whole
metaphor to help.
It was about cookies.
I have a friend who's an
artist, and this is an excuse
to get him to draw things.
And the idea here was to
use the big cookie model
where you're minimizing the
total number of transfers
that you are using
across the app lifecycle.
So if you have something
that's not time sensitive,
like analytics, you
queue that up and wait.
Next time there's a
user initiated refresh,
you send all of the queued data.
You also look into
the future to see
is there anything which
is going to be scheduled
to happen in a few minutes,
and let's just do that first.
So it was a way to
manually batch and bundle
all of your transfers so that
they happened at the same time,
and you get some
increased efficiency.
As I'm sure you can
believe, doing all of this
and understanding
how to do it right
was complicated enough that
a roomful of engineers, much
like yourselves, back
at Moscone believed
that this was a
legitimate equation you
needed to solve in
order to figure out
how to do this right.
It's not.
This is just made up.
By 2012, we had a
solution-- a solution,
which was the SyncAdapter.
And the SyncAdapter we claimed
was pretty straightforward,
which is fair to say was a lie.
Now, it's still better
than doing it all yourself.
Once you set it up, it's
not that complicated.
Right?
You're able to trigger a
one-off for a periodic transfer.
And a SyncAdapter will handle
all of the background work,
doing the batching
and time shifting
form multiple of your
requests that happen
within a sort of time window.
So you don't have to think
about when you trigger it.
You just do and
trust the SyncAdapter
to handle the timing for you.
Unfortunately, to
make this work you
needed to have a
SyncAdapter, fair enough.
SyncAdapter runs
within its own service.
Of course, you also need to have
an Account Manager, which isn't
used, but is part of the API.
And the Account Authenticator
also needs its own service
to run in.
OK.
I'm seeing a trend.
You also need to have
a content provider.
Again, doesn't need to be
used, but needs to exist.
You do all of this,
write it all in Java,
and then there's
maybe a dozen XML
files you need to write as
well, plus the manifest changes.
And then you're good to
go, your SyncAdapter works.
It's fair to say that a lot of
people trying to make this work
found it to be kind
of frustrating.
And of course, it only batched
and bundled your transfers
within your own app, which
is why 2013, great year,
Android 5, we introduced
the JobScheduler API,
which has now been replaced.
JobScheduler works at
the platform level.
So it does the
batching and bundling
for all of the apps
at the same time
to be able to take advantage not
just of several radio battery
improvements, but all of
the resource improvements
that we're trying to do, things
like stand by and [INAUDIBLE]
mode and all of this.
So within your app, you
create a new job service
that does the asynchronous
background updates.
In this case, we're
using the AsyncTask,
which we can use now because we
don't have the same memory leak
problems.
And then within your
specific activity,
you just define the
criteria that you
need in order for that job
to be successfully executed.
If it needs to be on the
interent, needs to be charging,
et cetera.
How urgent is it?
What is your preferred timing?
Is it periodic?
All of that sort of stuff.
And the JobScheduler
will then handle
all of the background
work for you
in the most efficient
way possible.
The only thing which would be
better than the JobScheduler
is if it worked in a backwards
compatible way, which
is why we launched Work Manager,
which is part of JetPack.
Now, to use Work Manager, it
works basically the same way.
You create a new
worker, and that
is where you are
defining the background
work that needs to be done.
And then within your activity,
you do the same thing.
You specify the
constraints that need
to be met before this
work can be accomplished.
And then WorkManager will
handle all of this for you
in the background,
same as JobScheduler.
But it now also encapsulates
the best practice solution
for earlier platform releases.
I think it goes back to 4.4.
So it'll use the latest
and greatest JobScheduler
if you're running on the latest
platform, all the way back
to probably AlarmManager, for
some of the earlier platform
releases.
And again, you
don't need to write
any of that boilerplate code
for backwards compatibility.
We do all of that for you.
You don't have to maintain
it, find the bugs,
find the edge cases.
You can rely on WorkManager
to take care of that.
And of course, this
is going to continue
to improve in future releases.
So as JobScheduler continues
to improve on the platform,
WorkManager is going to be able
to evolve to take advantage
of some of those changes.
You can learn all
about WorkManager.
And stage two today at 5:30,
I recommend going along.
It's a really cool new API.
So WorkManager,
it's great if it's
something which is
genuinely time consuming,
and it needs to be initiated
on the client side.
Now, one of the things
which we've always said,
and which really hasn't changed
is that wherever possible,
you should eliminate
periodic refreshes.
And any updates that need
to happen based on changes
on the server side should
be initiated by the server,
preferably using
Google Cloud Messaging.
By which, of course, I mean
Firebase Cloud Messaging,
because GCM was
deprecated in April.
Things move quickly.
Now, Firebase Cloud
Messaging takes
advantage of the same scalable,
reliable GCM infrastructure
that we've been
using in the past,
but also improves delivery
reporting and reliability.
It also adds a web console
so you can send notifications
to your apps without having to
have your own server instance.
Now, for transfers, this gives
us a pretty good solution.
But there's really
no way that this
is a viable solution for
being able to maintain
a small amount of data
whenever the phone rotates.
And for that matter, using
singletons or overwriting
the application class,
which I may or may not
have said in previous
years, is similarly
considered somewhat distasteful.
So which is why in
Android 3.0, we introduced
headless fragments and loaders.
I assume everyone is
familiar with both of these.
Fragments were designed
to break your UI up
into chunks that were
independent, reusable,
and interchangeable.
And the key was they were also
aware of the parent activity
lifecycle.
Now, the trick with
headless fragments
was that they didn't have a UI.
So you could configure them to
be retained across an activity
restart based on a
configuration change.
And this is really nice
because it meant now
we have some way to store
our data model that's
independent of the
activity being recreated
every time the
configuration changes.
But managing
fragments was tricky.
And if you attended the
first Android session
this morning here, you see
just how tricky it was.
You can add and remove
fragments from any activity.
You can have multiple
instances of the same fragment
within the same activity.
The fragment transactions
are all done asynchronously.
So you can't guarantee
when something is there.
And it's got its own
life cycle to manage.
Now, none of this was great.
All right?
You were able to
achieve what you wanted,
but it was complicated
to make this all work.
Now loading, loading was better.
Loaders made it easier to
asynchronously load data
within your fragments
and activities.
And then you could
observe and react
to changes in the loader
within the activity
based on whenever the
underlying data changed.
And in most cases, you had to
handle all of that plumbing
yourself, which meant you needed
to load the data from wherever
it was stored.
You needed to then observe
changes within that underlying
data and bubble it back
up through the loader
so that you could
have the simple code
in your activity, which was
unless you used CursorLoader.
Now, CursorLoader was great
because it did most of the work
for you.
You initialized the loader
within the activity or fragment
at creation time.
And then you just filled
in a number of callbacks
to create a new cursor and
then to receive the results
so that you can update
the UI accordingly.
Now, initializing a CursorLoader
was pretty straightforward.
You pass in the authority
of the content provider
that you want to query
in the SQL statement
that you want to use to
get back your results.
All that gets passed
into a ContentResolver.
It goes to your content
provider and gets
you back a cursor that you can
then use to update your UI.
But by definition,
that meant that you
needed to make your data
available via a content
provider.
Actually, you know what,
I'm going to come back
to content providers.
I'm just going to leave
them there for a moment.
OK.
So take a step back.
We've got headless
fragments and loaders.
And technically, that
enables us to do everything
that we need to do.
There's a problem, though.
It's really hard to get
them to work together,
understand how to make them
work across multiple activities
and fragments and the various
different implementations
of both.
In fact, getting it all to
work reliably and well was,
again, it was
frustrating, which is
why we're all so excited
to see Android Architecture
Components.
Android Architecture
Components introduced
ViewModels, LiveData,
and the room database.
And this all effectively
replaces fragments and loaders
as a simple way to separate
your UI and your UI data.
The ViewModel itself is actually
really simple to create.
You start with a property
that stores the data
that you want to expose.
In this case, we're
using a mutable LiveData
because LiveData is cool.
And then you expose
a method, which is
going to return that property.
And so the first time it's
going to populate that property.
And then from then on, it will
return that cached version.
Then you have a method
which does that population.
And again, this is
done asynchronously.
In this case, again, we
are using our old friend
the asynchronous task.
Then whenever the value of the
immutable LiveData changes,
that is going to
trigger any observers
that you have attached to it.
So back in your activity,
all you need to do
is request the ViewModels.
Ask for the specific ViewModel
class that you've just created.
And then call that
ViewModel's data
access method, which will
either then populate the data
and return it.
Either way, you'd add
an observer to that.
And then your
observed trigger is
going to get called, both
the first time you attach
the observer and then any
time the underlying LiveData
changes.
Now, the beauty of
ViewModels is that they
survive activity restart.
So we don't have to deal with
that particular scenario.
And the beauty of LiveData
is that it understands
the activity lifecycle.
So the first time
the app is run,
your ViewModel gets created,
populates the LiveData
from the underlying data
source, sends the results back
via the ObserveHandler
within your activity.
And then if someone
rotates their phone,
the activity gets
destroyed, gets recreated,
but the existing
ViewModel is returned.
The existing Data is returned
via the ObserveHandler.
And it's triggered with the
latest version of the data,
whether it's been updated
or not in the interim.
In fact, LiveData
is really smart
because it only sends updates
via the ObserveHandler
when the activity is active.
Because you don't need to update
the activity if the UI isn't
actually visible.
So if there is new data, it
will wait and then transfer it
once the activity
becomes active.
As a total result, what we
do is we feel less like this
and much more like this,
which is always our goal.
Content providers.
I promised I'd come back
to content providers.
And just as some context,
this is what happens.
This is the number
of students enrolled
in each of the lessons of
our Android Eudacity class.
And as you can see,
the highlighted columns
are when we get to content
providers and loaders.
So you get the impression
this is something that people
find a little frustrating.
We've improved it since then.
It's not quite so grim now.
And some of what we're
going to talk about now
actually explains some
of those improvements.
Why is it so frustrating?
Well this is the
boilerplate code
for creating a simple
content provider.
I'm sure many of you have
built something like this.
In truth, it's really just
the first couple of methods.
It goes on for a little while.
And now, keep in
mind, this isn't doing
anything particularly special.
It's just passing content
resolve requests straight
through to a SQLite database.
Now, obviously, that's
just the content provider.
Then you need to
create a contract that
defines the column names
that you want to use
to be able to interact with it.
Then, of course, you need to
create your own SQLite Open
Helper, which is how you
create, update, and access
the underlying database.
Now, all of this
operates on cursors,
which is probably not what
you're using in your UI.
So you'll need to create a
class to represent the records
in the database, just nice.
It's actually quite
simple in Kotlin.
But you'll also need code to
convert between those class
objects and conent values
to add rows to your tables.
And you'll need to
be able to convert
between cursors and lists
of your class objects.
Somewhere along
the line you need
to set up a bunch
of observers so
that if the database
changes, your list of objects
also gets updated.
It's a lot of code for
something which should
be relatively straightforward.
A quick one.
Is there anyone here who
gets paid per line of code?
No.
OK.
So if there is, and
you were just too shy,
that old method actually
works really well.
Stick with that.
For the rest of us, this is
where the Room Database really
comes into its own.
So it's part of Android
Architecture Components, now
part of Jetpack.
And all you need
to do is you start
with the class definition.
Right?
Defines the columns that
you want within your class.
And you just add an
annotation to say
this is an entity that I
want to use in a database.
And this is the primary
key for this table.
Then you create a
new Room Database,
which includes
each of the tables
that you want to have
within that database.
And you return an instance
of the data access object.
And that is the class where you
specify all of your database
interactions-- your
inserts, deletes, updates,
and your queries--
as many of them as you want
in as many different styles
as you want.
Now, you'll notice that the
queries here return LiveData.
And that's really cool because
if you're storing your UI data
in your ViewModel,
which obviously you
are because that's the
right way to do things now.
It actually simplifies that
ViewModel significantly.
You just request access to
the Room Database's access
object, execute the query,
which returns LiveData itself.
Then you just pass that
LiveData right back through
to any activity or
fragment which requests it.
Back in the activity,
it works the same way.
You've got the
same ObserveHandler
getting the same
LiveData representing
a collection of objects.
And you can use that to update
the UI whenever the underlying
database changes.
So you've got the same outcome
that you did before, but
10 times less boilerplate code.
10 times less code that you
have to maintain and alter.
If you change a column
name, beforehand, it
was a lot of places
that could go wrong.
Now, you just modify the class.
Now, if you combine that
with the WorkManager,
you actually get a really clean
solution to this whole process.
Right?
The WorkManager downloads
data from a server.
It updates the Room
Database accordingly,
which then sends the
LiveData to the ViewModel
within the activity
and fragment,
or fragment, that
you want to use,
which then via the
ObserveHandler updates the UI.
So if you're not one of the
lucky folks who are still
getting paid by
line of code, this
is probably a better solution.
So speaking of better solutions,
what else have we got?
I wanted to talk a little bit
about Android Location Services
because this is, again,
a topic that I've spent
a lot of time talking about.
Being able to find
the current position
and put it on a map
somewhere is something
that's been part of Android
since the very first beta SDK.
And so by 2011, I'd
actually managed
to amass quite a
collection of Protips
for how to take advantage
of the Location Manager
in the most efficient and
effective way possible.
It was a big topic in a couple
of my Android Protips talks.
So I went to the
location team, said
I've built a project which
encapsulates all of our best
practices, all of the things
which we tell people to do.
And it's fair to say
that they were impressed.
By which I mean it really
left an impression.
They then went away
and did what they do,
which is fixed everything.
And so where beforehand
I had all these classes
and interfaces they went
away and gave me an API
as part of the Fused
Location Provider, which
does all the magic for you.
It encapsulated all those best
practices within a small number
of simple APIs.
All you need to do here is
tell it what's more important,
battery life or accuracy.
How often do you
want to get results?
And the Fused Location
Provider goes and does
all of the hard work for you.
Now, that said, things
have changed a little bit.
In Oreo, we made some
changes, some new restrictions
about how you can
receive location updates
while your app is in
the background in order
to save battery life.
And specifically,
that means that if you
are in the background,
you only received
updates from Location Manager
or the FLP a few times an hour.
There's a few ways that
you can deal with this.
Right?
You can make a
foreground service, which
is what we do with navigation.
Another approach is
to use geofences.
So for those of you who
remember the very first version
of geofencing on Android
were proximity alerts.
Proximity alerts were bad.
Easy enough to set up, specify
a lat long or radius around
a point.
And they would fairly
reliably trigger
if you went across
that boundary.
Now the challenge
was the way that it
achieved that was by turning
on and leaving on your GPS.
So as long as you had
a proximity alarm set,
it would keep the GPS
running permanently,
which is not what the
documentation said.
But it is what happened.
Now luckily, the same
Google Play services launch,
which gave us the fused
location provider also
gave us a real
geofencing API, which
had all the functionality
that was claimed
to be done with
proximity alerts but also
gave you a few
additional improvements,
the most important of which
was that it didn't keep
the GPS locked permanently on.
We can take our geofences
to the next level
with the Awareness API,
which adds additional context
signals, which allow us to
make more complicated fences.
Specifically, we can
add date and time,
proximity to beacons, user
activity, if they're walking,
cycling, driving,
and device state.
And you can combine all
those conditions together,
such as in this example where
we have one fence, which
is triggered if you drive
within 1,000 meters of a given
location between 10 and six.
We have a little
bit of time left.
One thing I learned in 2018
is that there's a new way to--
I'm sorry, that
should be there's
a new way to control media.
Right.
Now back in the day,
controlling media playback
was done with MediaPlayer.
I'm going to buzz through
this pretty quickly.
Mainly, it meant that you had to
listen to media buttons getting
clicked.
Now, of course, you
can control media
a bunch of different ways.
So we've got a better
solution, which
is Exoplayer, which effectively
replaces the framework media
players, easy to
customize and extend.
Again, I'm not going to go
through the full details here.
I had a couple of slides, but I
have been speaking too slowly.
So I recommend that you go to
Mark and Andrew's talk tomorrow
morning at 10:30 to
get all of the details.
Now, not all of the changes
in Android have been in code.
Some of the biggest
changes are actually
in the availability
of Android expertise.
Back when we started, we didn't
have Slack and Google developer
experts.
We didn't even have
Stack Overflow.
What we did have was IRC.
We had Google developer groups.
We had some DevRel people,
which spoke at conferences.
And that still kind of
happens, but the big change now
is that we're just voices
within a much larger developer
ecosystem.
There are now lots and lots
of people around the world who
help each other.
This is just a small selection
of the 90 Google developer
experts specializing
in Android and Kotlin
all around the world.
So this is just a small amount
of the extended engineering
team that we have
helping the community.
Similarly, we've got
Android conferences
all around the world.
This is a small selection of
some of the Android events
that people pointed out to me
on Twitter a couple of weeks
ago when I asked what the best
conferences to go to were.
Because really, the biggest
tip that I can give you
is that, much more than
changes in the tooling
or the frameworks of the APIs
or Jetpack or anything else,
much more than that,
the biggest thing
driving Android development
forward is the community.
It's the people around
you, the people online.
We're all helping each
other with Android.
And it's important
because we know
that the one thing
that doesn't change
is that things are
going to change.
So take advantage of things like
Jetpack to make things simpler.
Work with the people around you.
And hopefully your apps
will survive much longer
than my pro tips.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]